-Welcome, everybody.
Welcome to "The Tonight Show"!
You're here. You made it.
Thank you for watching at home.
Guys, today is December 1st,
which means it's time
to play that
classic December game,
"Can you finish your lunch
before the sun goes down?"
Yeah, that's right.
It's December 1st.
The holiday season is here.
I hate to be old-fashioned,
but does anyone else think
Christmas has taken
all the meaning away from
the Lexus December to Remember?
You can tell it's the
holiday season in New York City.
This morning, I told my Uber
driver, "Rockefeller Center,"
and he just abandoned his car
and never came back.
Yep, now that
the Rockefeller Center
Christmas tree is up,
there are tourists everywhere.
And now that weed
is legal in New York,
I kind of understand
staring at it for an hour.
I go...
Well, it seems like there's
so much going on right now.
Last night was the Rockefeller
Center Christmas tree got lit.
The World Cup --
[ Cheers and applause ]
The World Cup is in full swing.
There's a new trailer for the
"Super Mario Bros. Movie."
-Ooh!
-That looks good.
And Subway just announced that
they're going to sell
a foot-long cookie.
There's a lot to go over,
so let's just jump in
and cover it all at once.
It's time for a "News Smash."
♪♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
First up, the Rockefeller Center
Christmas tree.
Last night was the big lighting.
Thousands of people
waited around for hours
just for one second
of excitement.
Yeah, it was
just like watching...
the World Cup.
Yeah.
Games are long,
sometimes there's a tie,
and the fans in Qatar
aren't even allowed to drink.
But it hasn't stopped them
from enjoying the matches,
which are full of
running, jumping, and kicking,
kind of like...
"Super Mario."
The new trailer for
the movie just came out.
Yeah, it's a whole movie
about a plumber,
which is exactly who you'll
be calling if you eat a...
foot-long cookie from Subway.
That's right --
a giant 12-inch-long cookie.
They're selling them
for National Cookie Day
or, as stoners call it...
Christmas.
The tree is so beautiful
when it's lit.
But you know
who isn't lit right now?
Fans at the World Cup.
There's no booze.
But they still went wild when
Team USA's best player scored
while getting kneed
in the groin.
Yeah, he took one
right in his...
cookies.
Seriously, if there's --
If you eat this whole thing,
you won't be hitting your
weight-loss...
goooooal!
[ Cheers and applause ]
There are 16 countries left,
but there can only be
one winner.
Right now,
every country is hoping...
"it's a-me."
So, in conclusion...
what a star...
in Qatar...
"Super Mar"...
you took it too far.
This has been a "News Smash."
♪♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
Oh, thank you very much.
Thank you.
Well, here's some big news.
Today, President Biden hosted
French President Emmanuel Macron
for the first White House state
dinner in more than three years.
Yep, the French like
to eat late,
so Biden was like, "Got it.
4:30 it is."
Can we see
Biden and Macron together?
Oh, yeah.
Yeah, they look like
a father-and-son law firm.
Tonight, Biden was --
It was the very first
White House state dinner
with Emmanuel Macron.
Now, state dinners
are always very fancy
with lots of dishes and courses.
So, just out of curiosity,
let's see if I can read
the entire menu in less time
than it took Macron to break
away from a handshake
with Donald Trump.
Here we go. Let's try it.
And let's run the handshake.
Here we go.
Butter-poached Maine lobster.
American caviar.
Squash raviolo
with tarragon sauce.
Beef with shallot marmalade.
That sounds good.
Triple-cooked butter potatoes.
Sunchoke-cream-watercress
red-wine reduction.
Three artisanal cheeses.
Orange chiffon cake.
And roasted pears and ice cream.
There you go.
That's a good menu.
We did it.
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
-[ As Trump ] Oh!
-[ As Trump ]
♪ Ring around the rosie ♪
♪ Pocket -- ♪
[ Normal voice ] No.
Meanwhile, last night,
the Bidens and the Macrons
went out to dinner
at an Italian restaurant.
-Ooh!
-Yeah.
Here's a photo of
the two couples at dinner.
There they are.
Yep, the Bidens and Macrons
went on a double date.
Then Kamala and Doug
showed up at the restaurant
and pretended
it was an accident.
"Oh, my gosh!
You eat at the same...
I guess we should
just eat together, right?"
Switching gears.
Well, guys, Prince William
and Princess Kate
are on a trip in Boston.
And last night, they went to
a Boston Celtics game.
And there's a photo going around
that really made me laugh.
Can we see this photo?
The photo already inspired
that new meme...
Did you guys hear about this?
There's a new study
from scientists in California
that found that
eating foods with a high --
-Jimmy!
-Wait, wait.
-Jimmy,
I thought we were friends.
-Wait. Keke.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Keke Palmer!
♪♪
Keke Palmer. Keke Palmer?
-Jimmy...
-What?
-...I said,
"I thought we were friends."
-No, we are friends.
Of course, we're friends.
-Well, then why didn't
you say that I'm hosting
"SNL" this week
with musical guest SZA?
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Well...
You just did.
-Yeah, but you didn't.
-Oh, sure.
Keke Palmer is hosting "SNL"
this week with
musical guest SZA!
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Thanks, Jimmy.
I knew we were friends.
-Yeah, we are best friends.
-Bye, guys.
-That's Keke Palmer right there.
This weekend.
I'm rooting for you.
Break a leg.
♪♪
Guys -- Oh,
she's going to crush it.
Guys, listen to this.
According to new research,
self-service checkouts
at grocery stores are
covered in harmful bacteria.
But, hey, at least
they also never work.
I love that, two years ago, we
were wiping down every surface,
and now we're like,
"Eh, my immune system
needs the challenge."
Also, I read that researchers
in Europe developed a robot
that braces itself
against walls to avoid falling.
The robot's also programmed
to say, "I don't have a problem.
You have a problem."
Too bad they don't have
that for humans.
-[ Laughs ]
-What?!
What?!
We have to see it again.
Can we see that one more time?
It's just too funny.
-[ Laughs ]
-Oh!
-Oh, my God.
-Well, this is cool.
I saw that the new
"Addams Family" series,
"Wednesday," just passed
"Stranger Things"
for most hours viewed
in a week on Netflix.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Yeah.
Tariq, are you
watching "Wednesday"?
-Watching what Wednesday?
-"Wednesday."
-Yeah.
What are you watching Wednesday?
-No, it's called "Wednesday."
You can watch whenever --
Monday, Tuesday,
Wednesday, Thursday.
-Are those other shows?
-No, just "Wednesday."
I'm a "Wednesday" watcher.
-Oh, I love "The Watcher."
I watched it Wednesday.
-You watch "The Watcher" on
Wednesday, but not "Wednesday"?
-No, no, you can watch
"The Watcher" whenever you want,
even Wednesday.
Just watch "The Watcher,"
not "Wednesday."
-So you watched "The Watcher,"
not "Wednesday," on Wednesday
while I was watching
"Wednesday" on Wednesday
and not "The Watcher"?
-That's the first thing
you've said that made
any sense tonight.
-Oh, Tariq Trotter, everyone.
Thank you very much. That's --
♪♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
Well, last night was the
Rockefeller Center tree lighting
here in New York,
but it was also
the national tree lighting
in D.C.
That's right --
two Christmas-tree lightings.
Yeah. The national tree lighting
will be broadcast by CBS
in two weeks.
And I feel like
they're a little competitive,
because here's the promo
they just released.
-Season's greetings, America.
Are you tired of
lame Christmas tree lightings
at Rockefeller Center?
Well [bleep] that [bleep]
because the National Christmas
Tree Lighting is where it's at!
We've got everything --
colorful lights, this star,
a DJ named Splashy Dan!
Rock Center's got
a cute, little squirrel.
-Loser!
-But we got Cocaine Bear!
[ Bear roars ]
And cocaine squirrel!
And you think DJ Dan's
not on cocaine?
He's on three drugs
you haven't even heard of!
I hope you like ornaments,
because this Christmas tree's
got balls to the wall!
So, this holiday season,
suck it, Rockefeller Center!
Come watch a
real Christmas tree get lit!
Ho-ho!
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Wow!
Wow!
That is competitive.
"It's Chrishmash, bish?"
-I have no idea.
What are they
doing over there at CBS?
-What do they do at CBS?
-Oh, my gosh.
Finally, we have
exactly 12 shows left
before we go on Christmas break.
Yeah, that's right.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Which means it's time for
that beloved
"Tonight Show" tradition.
It's time for "12 Days of
Christmas Sweaters"!
-♪ "12 Days of
Christmas Sweaters ♪
♪ 12 days left ♪
-That's right.
Every show between
now and Christmas,
we'll be giving
one lucky audience member
an out-of-this-world
Christmas sweater
from the Countdown to
Christmas Cabinet.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Since there are 12 shows left,
let's open door number 12.
[ Audience "Oohs" ]
Hello.
-Hello.
-Nice to meet you.
-Nice to meet you, too.
-Oh!
♪♪
It's a sweater.
Oh, my goodness.
This is like a...
[ Cheers and applause ]
Got mittens.
It's got mittens there.
This is gorgeous.
It's a Christmas sweater.
Now let's see who's going
home with tonight's sweater.
Everyone look at
your seat number.
If I call your number,
come on down.
Quest, can I get
a drumroll, please?
[ Drumroll ]
Who wants a sweater?!
[ Cheers and applause ]
It is 211!
♪♪
Come on over, bud. Hey.
How you doing, bud?
Nice to see you.
Why don't you head over there.
Yeah, go over there.
Nice to see you.
How are you? What is your name?
-Mike.
-Mike, where are you from?
-New York.
-Mike from New York. I love it.
-Whoo!
[ Cheers and applause ]
I like your sweatshirt.
Is that just a politeness
or is that a weed reference?
-A little bit of --
A little bit of both.
-A little bit of both. Yeah.
Mike, in New York,
it gets a little cold.
Do you have anything
like this at home?
-I actually have
an elf onesie, so--
-Oh, this is
going to go perfect.
You can lend that out
to someone else
and go to the party
wearing this one.
Would you like to try it on?
-I guess so.
-Yeah, go for it. Yeah.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Yes, that's very nice.
Alright, Mike,
this is going to be good.
Mike, I feel like
this is going to work.
-Yeah? You think so?
-Yeah.
I feel like this is your thing.
Yeah, yeah.
They're for--
You're forced to wear mittens
while wearing
this sweater, yeah.
Oh, this is perfect.
The thumbs reverse
on that one, so, yeah,
you have to get your hand --
Oh, this is -- Mike...
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Thank you.
-Oh, my God.
There he goes right there,
Mike from New York.
[ Cheers and applause ]
You look fantastic, buddy.
-Thank you.
-Let's give Mike
another round of applause.
Stick around.
We'll be right back with
Adam Sandler, everybody.
Come on back.
♪♪
[ Cheers and applause ]